vsauce kevin here with a math crime so
sinister that the michigan supreme court
stated no other game operated more
extensively or demoralized so many
people city police forces repeatedly
shut it down and the fbi waged all-out
war against it and it made criminals out
of people like a detroit mom named miss
fanny what they didn't know is that they
were fighting against a nearly perfect
game that was about way more than just
beating the odds
[Music]
in atlanta it was called playing the bug
in harlem and elsewhere it's still
called policy after the original game
that drew numbers from 1 to 78 but the
real name is just numbers and although
it was associated with black communities
everyone played the numbers when fanny
davis set up her detroit neighborhood
numbers game in 1958 there just wasn't
much economic opportunity for the black
community so she started her own
business and she funded it after winning
big on numbers herself
it worked like this you'd place a bet on
a three-digit number from zero zero zero
to nine nine nine and that could hit one
of two ways you could play it straight
where you hope to hit the exact number
like six 607 and you'd be paid 500 or
600 times your bet or you could bet a
number boxed meaning you'd win if any
combination of your numbers hit that's 3
factorial so 3 times 2 times 1 equals 6
possible combinations and it would pay
about 80 to 1. ok so how did they choose
the winning number
i've got a cage full of balls numbered 1
through 100.
i'll give this a crank and then i'll
draw three i'm gonna play three nine
four that's my lucky number because 394
was tony gwynn's batting average in 1994
when he was on pace to hit over 400 for
the first time since ted williams had
406 in 1941 but a labor strike shortened
the baseball season and ruined
everything
[Music]
okay here we go
i already lost oh let's keep going
[Music]
a cage of balls broke oh
man
oh
hi i'm a fool ah there's so many on the
floor all right let's finish this off
stay closed
last number
the winning number was 261 my number is
394.
sorry tony but this method is silly no
one would trust a guy pulling balls out
of a cage in his house to get the
winning number in a more fair manner i
could do something like take three
youtube videos reload them each day on a
live stream and use the ones digit from
the view count to pick the winning
number and fanny's game worked kind of
similar to that she used a mutual from a
local race track the betting totals for
win place and show on a series of horse
races she take the ones digit from the
fourth fifth and sixth race totals and
there's your three numbers it was
technically possible to influence those
digits but incredibly difficult and
expensive other games used independent
numbers like digits from the published
daily balance of the us treasury things
you could open up a newspaper and see
look here's the real beauty of numbers
and why it worked so well for fanny and
her community you win just often enough
to enjoy playing and to validate every
possible betting system if you play six
days a week you'll probably win boxed
two or three times a year and you'll hit
straight for 500 times your bet every
few years did a number come to you in a
dream do you think you have a scientific
lottery beating system they all end up
winning and yeah the house edge was
steep getting paid 500 to 1 on something
you know has a 1 in 1 000 chance of
happening means someone's making money
somewhere there also taking bets keeping
meticulous records collecting money from
losses and distributing money from wins
all as they're calculating their own
mathematical risk of ruin in real time
to make sure they can survive
financially if someone hits big but for
fannie's neighbors they could see one
dollar become 500
overnight the fbi saw an opportunity to
rip it away from them and give it to
someone else
we'll get to that in a second this video
is sponsored by fabulous about eighty
percent of new year's resolutions fail
within the first two months because
habit changing and building are hard
fabulous was developed at duke
university's center for advanced
hindsight and is designed to help you
create long-lasting change in your daily
routine based on behavioral science and
decades of research it works by breaking
down healthy habits into very small
tasks that you can easily achieve every
single day so whether your goal is to
exercise more sleep better eat healthier
or dedicate yourself to an 80 speed run
personal best of ninja guided 3 for the
nes fabulous offers a self-guided
approach to better habit forming and if
you want a guided approach they have
that too use it to start building your
ideal daily routine right now the first
100 people who click the link below will
get 25 off their fabulous subscription
and thanks to fabulous for supporting
vsauce2
okay
law enforcement called the numbers game
racketeering and in 1970 the fbi led
what j edgar hoover called the largest
gambling raid in history shutting down
58 numbers operators then governments
realize that if the house always wins
they could just become the house states
made numbers illegal did their best to
wipe it out and then
gave themselves a legal numbers monopoly
wow
what a neat trick
lotteries actually have a really complex
history in the united states from the
colonial period to early statehood
hundreds of lotteries helped raise money
for schools and public works by the
1830s lotteries were denounced by social
reformers as morally bankrupt predatory
games that generated tainted revenue and
in 1895 lottery games were banned
nationwide from legal lotteries to
policy houses there was enough
corruption and game fixing to consider
what was best for the public interest
now 44 states have legalized lotteries
and the powerball is played in all of
them to help raise money for schools and
public works
and we've come full circle but the
reality is to run a game like numbers
what you really need is the trust of
your community
danny davis and other boutique numbers
operators engaged in a sort of prescient
scholarship decades before neuroscience
and psychology research confirmed what
they
harnessed intuitively the community
element of numbers was everything they
seized the power of dunbar's number
building on the social cohesion in
well-connected neighborhoods so everyone
could play a game together and that's
completely lost when 100 000 strangers
play a lottery anonymously at a gas
station they knew that throwing in just
one additional number meant only hitting
straight once every 30 years that's
probably once in a lifetime and that's
just not often enough for most people to
want to keep playing even if it
increases the prizes dramatically they
intuited the communal strength of renee
gerard's memetic desire and how much
people love playing games together
and
need to and they also knew how to make a
small economy work numbers created tens
of thousands of jobs within communities
trying to survive in the face of
discrimination
segregation and
rampant racism a 1903 detroit free press
article said numbers was largely the
gambling field of the ignorant
superstitious and poor the main thing is
to have the evil eternally wiped out
lottery ban legislation was a
patronizing attempt to protect
communities from themselves
now we've got japan's takarakuji south
korea's lotto 645 the us mega millions
and russia's gaslato in addition to u.s
state games that operate exactly like
numbers did decades ago
pennsylvania even named their
three-digit lottery the daily
number
but those games can't possibly do what
people like fanny davis did in detroit
there's no talk at the diner about who
won that week or who hasn't hit in ages
there's no knock on the door to deliver
your lucky payout the day after your
numbers match there's no playing 357
because you live at 357 park drive and
everyone knowing that when that number
hit
you were the winner
that's all gone
there's enough intrigue about fanny
davis life and her numbers game to fill
a great docu-series and there were
thousands like her read bridgette davis
book about her mom that's her story to
tell not mine check out felicia george's
dissertation about numbers in detroit or
louise merriweather's novel daddy was a
number runner you've heard a million
stories about the good guys and the bad
guys during prohibition but
number stories like miss fannie's have
been almost entirely ignored but they
shouldn't be because alongside the
rackets were people who understood the
social fabric of their communities
making your own way in the world and
making everyone else a little bit
happier that's not the american dream
that's everyone's dream but the highly
regulated mass production of fun strips
the complex social function from a game
that's the perfect blend of math and
people
it's reduced to lonely
anonymous
gambling
and when that happens
the only thing left
is just
numbers
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you